for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
so in this video the actual process of
ketone body synthesis or ketogenesis one
thing we should keep in mind for sure is
where this is all happening and that's
of course happening in the liver
mitochondrial matrix and before we
actually get into the reactions and
what's going on with everything I just a
heads up I'm I've numbered the carbons
in the atoms in some cases 1 2 3 4 in
this case here with these two acetyl
COAS
and just as a heads-up that's not the
actual numbering or nomenclature
convention sort of situation that's just
a way for me to kind of help you
visualize what's going on along with the
color coding like this one's blue in
this one's green just to kind of see
what's connecting to what we can keep
track of things okay but it's not the
actual conventions okay with that said
let's get into it so the first the first
thing is that we're going to take these
acetyl co ways and we're going to
combine them together in a condensation
reaction basically what's going to
happen is that we're going to connect
carbon number 2 of this one it's a
carbon number 3 of this one while losing
this coenzyme a so that coenzyme a is
going to be lost and we're going to
connect those two carbons to get acetyl
acetyl co a so we can see here that
carbon number 2 bound to carbon number 3
there okay so that first reaction there
is a condensation of two acetyl co a
molecules right and a condensation
reaction is just a a reaction that forms
a carbon-carbon bond okay and this
specific step is catalyzed by an enzyme
called thiolase
which we've actually seen before where
have we seen this enzyme before we've
seen it in the last step of beta
oxidation which is a process we
mentioned in the previous video the last
step of beta oxidation was a cleavage
reaction right cleaving you know in the
process of breaking down a fatty acid
cleaving off an acetyl co a
is catalyzed by a thiolase so this is
that same enzyme and what's hat we can
see here is a double arrow is that the
cleavage reaction is reversible and it's
the first step here in ketone body
synthesis so that gives us a CO CO CO
away and the next step is going to take
this Osito Osito co a and turn it into
this molecule here hm g co a for short
the actual full name is beta hydroxy
beta method with chiral co a and the way
this forms you'll notice that this this
part here of the molecule is new it's
got carbons 5 & 6 where those come from
they came from another acetyl co a
molecule okay and so what happens is
that carbon number 6 is actually
connecting to carbon number 3 and we're
losing the coenzyme a that's coming so
this carbon right here is connecting to
carbon number 3 and what ends up
happening is that these electrons are
gonna be pushed up and this oxygen ends
up being protonated to have the Oh H
group okay so now we've got beta hydroxy
methyl what's your o a this this is the
the next molecule that we have so
basically what's happening here is we're
forming another carbon-carbon bond so
it's another condensation reaction with
another acetyl co a that's coming in
okay and so like I said we make hmg-coa
which is a molecule we've actually seen
before and the the enzyme that makes it
here is hmg-coa synthase now where have
we seen hmg-coa before well we've seen
it before in cholesterol synthesis I
have a video series on that cholesterol
synthesis that's different though here
this is happening in the liver
mitochondria where as cholesterol
synthesis occurs in the liver cytosol so
these are pretty much completely
separate as far as compartments in the
cell go okay next up we're going to take
hmg-coa and we are going to turn it into
a pseudo acetate which is our actual
ketone body this is an actual ketone
body here
what happened well we basically lost
this part of the molecule here okay and
so we're going to lose an acetyl co a
here once you lose an acetyl co a those
one in two carbons and we're left with a
pseudo acetate so that's like I said
that's our ketone body so here we're
basically cleaving off that portion
there and so this is a cleavage to yield
see the acetate our ketone body and the
enzyme that catalyzes this reaction is
called hmg-coa leaves
now this acetyl acetate can give rise to
acetone via a decarboxylation reaction
and decarboxylation just means in losing
a carbon dioxide that specific carbon
dioxide that would be lost I'll be right
here
carbon overfly with those two oxygens
that can leave as a carbon dioxide and
so that can occur spontaneously or it
can be catalyzed by a co acetate
decarboxylase decarboxylase because it's
removing a carboxyl group or carbon
dioxide and it's acting lastly the last
tape so we could lose that carbon
dioxide that one carbon there and give
rise to acetone now that normally
happens very infrequently okay should
write this in white not brown
infrequently that's easier see alright
happens very infrequently okay and
that's actually a good thing because
acetone is toxic okay now what we'll see
kind of later something we'll touch on a
little bit about the sort of toxicity of
these ketone bodies but acetone being
toxic what happens in in diabetes um a
lot of it can be produced and it's so
much so that it's I mentioned that it
could be exhaled before right it is
possible to actually smell it in a
patient's breath so sometimes that's
used for diagnosing diabetes
although no medical advice here if
you're at all concerned about anything
hit up your doctor okay
okay so yeah so acetoacetate can be
turned into acetone via decarboxylation
okay but it can also be turned into de
beta-hydroxybutyrate now what happens
there is that the acetyl acetate we can
see here that basically the carbonyl
group right here gets converted into a
hydroxyl group and the enzyme that
catalyzes this reaction is called D beta
hydroxy butyrate dehydrogenase where you
see here that it's reversible
okay dehydrogenases they are associated
with redox reactions and we can see here
that we're going from two bonds to an
oxygen to one bond to an oxygen by two
bonds they're two oxygen at the double
bond just one here we also gained out
hydrogen so acetoacetate was oxidized or
reduced let you guess there it was
reduced right it has less bonds to
oxygen more bonds to hydrogen so it was
reduced which means something else was
oxidized in this case what was oxidized
it was specifically an NADH NADH was
oxidized to yield nad plus in this
reduction reaction okay so now we
basically created D beta hydroxy
butyrate ketone body okay okay cool so
we've made the ketone bodies now what
well this all happened in the liver
mitochondrial matrix right they deliver
mitochondrial matrix and so what happens
is that these ketone bodies they're
going to travel in the blood to extra
hepatic tissues extrahepatic tissues to
be used for energy okay now something I
want you to keep in mind is that in in
healthy individuals this is not
happening to a great extent this is
happening very very little very few
ketone bodies are synthesized under
normal conditions okay it's normal for
it to for ketone bodies to be
synthesized but not to a great extent
okay anyway that
this video I hope it was helpful thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying